except I it's kind of like mac and
cheese for me it's easy to make you can
make a lot of it and my mom used to make
X over all the time for my lunch
[Music]
so the first recipe is classic yakisoba
tasty Japan's making four different
buttons here basically excavates usually
needle cabbage kara bean sprout thinly
sliced pork tossed with the yakisoba
sauce which is sweet savory and tangy
all at the same time very similar to
okonomiyaki sauce but slightly thinner
it's kind of like Japanese chairman you
may only be familiar with the basic
style but there are a bunch of different
way of making it the second of its salt
and lemon I started seeing a lot of
trend where salt lemon combination it's
getting very popular in Japan this is
lighter than the sauce one also yakisoba
you often will find on the street it's
very much a Japanese Street food you can
also find in Japan an instant version so
you can just pour hot water drain the
water and add sauce it's kind of like
mulch and ramen but we have this
reaction of ajanta the options are
unlimited the third one is the Takumi
chip with all its pork and kimchi pork
and kimchi flavor combination is very
popular as well if you go to an
okonomiyaki place you will see this
flavor combination very often it's a
Japanese take on more of Korean style
dish I feel like it's more Japanese
people have started using kimchi in our
daily food so I think it's kind of a
fusion you can order your favorite
vegetables and protein and make it a
little healthier and
make it fancy the fourth one is a little
bit fancy it's mostly food
he had shrimp and squid he also has a
little quail egg
well egg it's super easy to find every
grocery store has it pretty much you may
only be familiar with the basic style
but there are bunch of different ways to
make yakisoba that you should strike
it's easy and simple with proteins and
vegetables nutritious and delicious dish
there are a lot of different way of
making it if you have any other creative
ideas let me know go make it and go make
it fancy
[Music]